مساء الخير منطقه شرق البحر المتوسط اصبحت
اخطر من اي وقت مضى على استقرار العالم مع
تزايد الاساطيل هناك الدول المختلفه
وتزايد التوتر
زياده فرص الاحتقان
تقديري انه فيه سببين اساسيين زياده
التوتر في منطقه شرق البحر المتوسط يتهم
دون العالم كلها السبب الاول ان ي هو تغير
النظام العالمي من النظام بيعتمد على دوله
واحده عظمى يعني نظام احادي القطب الى
الولايات المتحده الى نظام متعدد الاقطاب
او الثلاث الاقطاب تحديدا بيضم مع
الولايات المتحده
الروس والصينيين والسبب التالي هو اكتشاف
الفائز على كميات وفيره في هذه المنطقه
ربما يكون اسهل المدخل لفهم اللي بيقرى
هناك وتشابك العلاقات ان احنا ناخذ الثاني
الاول وهو اكتشاف الغاز اشرنا الى بردو
بشكل سريع في احدى الحلقات
وبعيدا من 2013 بدا يتم اكتشاف الغاز في
المنطقه منطقه شرق البحر المتوسط وكانت
اول دوله تكتشف الغازهي اسرائيل وبعد كده
قبرص واليونان
وبعدين مصر في 2014
اكتشفت حق الزهر الكبير او الضخمه او
الاضخم يعني في المنطقه الحقيقه انه لما
نشوف الكميات اللي اعلن عنها نلاحظ ان
الكميات مش هيك طبعا وفيره لكن ما كميات
ضخمه جدا يعني مثلا تعادل احتياطات
الولايات المتحده او روسيا وهي دوله عظمى
في مجال الطاقه وللكميات اللي تم اكتشافها
حتى هذه اللحظه بتعادل تقريبا ثلث
الاحتياطات الموجوده في الولايات المتحده
واحد على عشره من الاحتياط الموجوده لدى
روسيا ولا تقارن بالكميات اللي موجوده لدى
الايرانيين والقطر او في استراليا ومع ذلك
الكميات اللي موجوده هناك
جايين جورج يعني قادره على تغيير قواعد
اللعبه لثلاثه اسباب السبب الرئيسي في ان
هي قريبه بحكم موقعها حكمه موقع ال منطقه
الشرق ال البحر المتوسط قريبه من الاتحاد
الاوروبي او الدول الاوروبيه وهي سوق هام
جدا
الغاز وهذا السوق يعتمد بشكل رئيسي على
استعداد الروسي ثم الغاز الايراني
وغالبا هذا الغاز بيمر من خلال ال جزء منه
بامر من خلال الاراضي التركيه
الاوروبيين يتمنون ان يحصلوا على الغاز
ولكن من مصادر مختلفه يعني لا من الروس
ولا من الايرانيين ويتمنى ان ما يكونش
الماضي ترقيات بسبب توتر العلاقه مع الدول
الثلاث وبالتالي اكتشاف الغاز قريبا في
هذه المنطقه قريبه من الدول اوروبا
بيمثل امل وفرصه للاتحاد الاوروبي الى
تنويع مصادر و بيمثل في المقابل تحدي
للدول الثلاث اللي انا ذكرتها روسيا
وايران
والتوتير ال السبب الثالث اللي بيخلي
المساله مهمه اوي انه صرح ان الكميات
عملاقه يعني زي ما انا ذكرت ولكن في نفس
الوقت هي الكبيره بما يكفي بحيث انها تمثل
مساله حياه او موت للدول اللي ظهر فيها
الغاز اللي انا ذكرتها ال اسرائيل ومصر
واليونان وقبرص
والى حضراتكم مثال انه مثلا بلدى مصر
مثال بمصر لانها الاكبر عددا بتكلم على
مائه مليون مواطن بيستهلك يوميا بارقام
اليوم حوالي سته خمسه سته ونص مليار قدم
مكعبه يوميا من الغاز لو افترضنا ان هذه
الكميات اه يعني مع ثلاث هذه الكميات
افترضنا الكمادات
لم تتصاعد بحسبه بسيطه تكتشف انه حق
اللي هو بيحتوي على ثلاثين ترليون قدم
مكعب ممكن يكفى احتياجات المصريه لمده عشر
سنوات وبالتالي المساله مساله
اكتشاف الغاز بدا تحت التحالفات تحالفت
الدول المستفيده من الاكتشافات الجديده في
شرق المتوسط وتحالف للدول المتطوره الدول
المستفيده اللي انا ذكرتها قوات التحالف
في شكل منتدى سموه الكاس اوريجينال كاس
فور او منتدى غاز البحر المتوسط مصر
ومعها اليونان ومعها قبرص معها اسرائيل
واخذوا معها السلطه الفلسطينيه وضمه مع
الاردن
واعتبرها انها نستهلك رئيس الغاز جيد دول
كون التحالف وهذا التحالف مدعوم بشده من
اوروبا طبعا لانه اوروبا
عندك هذا الغاز مش بس عشان شركاتها تشتغل
ولكن عشان هي محتله الغاز وتسعى الان الى
الاستثمار في اه
انبوب غاز ياخذ من الامور اللي موجوده
هناك ويبدل اوروبا بشكل مباشر
الدول المستفيده
ومدرب ايضا من الولايات المتحده هذا
التحالف تحالف الدول المتضرره طبعا تركيا
ومن ثم ايران ومعهم روسيا الدولي بتحاول
ان هي وتحديدا تركيا وايران بيحاولوا ان
هم يقللوا الاضرار من التحالف المقابل
وبيحاولوا يكفوا عليه باكثر من طريقه و
معهم روسيا بس انا بتكلم اللي بتكلم على
تركيا وايران اكثر نفوس اولا قوه عظمى
موجوده في اه في في السنوات الاخيره في
التحالفات المختلفه بعضها تحالفات
وتحالفات مضاده لكن في كل الاحوال التحالف
الدولي الثلاثه بدا الهم
يتحايل علي يعني مخرجات التحالف المستفيد
احد نتائج تحالف الدول الثلاثه ان مثلا
ماده خط جديد الى اوروبا يمد الغاز يمد
الغاز الروسي عبر تركيا الى الاوروبيين
اللي هو ترك ستين قابلين محاوله تركيا
انها تساعد ايران على الالتفاف على
العقوبات التي فرضتها الولايات المتحده
عليها بتمرير تجارتها خصوصا من الطاقه اذا
كانت مشتقات الطاقه المختلفه من بيترول
وغاز عبر اراضيها الى الراغبين في الشراء
خصوصا في من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي لاحظ
انه
ال اوروبا في كل الاحوال تحتاج الغاز لكن
تتمنى انه يكون الغاز من مصادر
خلاف الدول الثلاث دول
التلاته والدوله الثلاثه بتستفيد انها
تخلي اوروبا رهينه ل اه قدرتها على انتاج
الغاز او انها
او انها تكون بعض الغاز كما هو في حاله
تركيا نتيجه وجود التحالف والتحالف المضاد
اللي قام على
اثر اكتشاف الغاز بدات تظهر
صراعات في صراعات واضحه ومباشره ابرزها
اسراع ما بين تركيه وما بين قوس وتسرع
قديم عمره نصف قرن تقريبا
ونتج عنه ان سنه اربعه وسبعين احتلت جزء
من
كثيره تقول الاحتلال قائمه الان بشكل غير
مباشر بان هي اعلان الدوله سمتها
الجمهوريه القبارصه الاتراك ودي وتعترف
بها دوله واحده بس فيه العالم اللي هي
تركيا في كل الاحوال ده موضوع ثاني لكن
النتيجه مع ظهور الغاز تستفيد الغاز بحكم
القوانين المياه وال القوانين الدوليه
يعني تستفيد من قبرص ولن تستفيد الجزيره
الصغيره وسوف تحرم منه تركيا الامر الذي
يدفع تركيا الى التحرك القبارصه
اليونانيين اذا تحرك مش بس
توصل الى حد التهديد باستخدام الاسطول ان
تركي لمنع
القبارصه ومنع اليونانيين من استكشاف اي
كميه من الغاز او الحفر هناك ومنعت احد
الحفارات الايطاليه لكن تدخله ال ال ال اه
ال يعني تدخلت عسكريا ايطاليا وتدخلت
عسكريه المصر بحيث انه تتاكد ان هذه
المنطقه اللي كلهم ستكون درسا واصحاب
مصالح في استمرار ضخ الغاز والبحث عنه في
ردع ال ال الاتراك
صراع مباشر هو الصراع كان موجود ونائب
اكثر من خمسه واربعين سنه وزي ما قلت
لحضراتكم انه الاوروبيين بيعتبروا وجود
الاطراف في قبرص اطول احترام
الاحتلال في اوروبا ولكن الاحتلال او
الاحتقان ال الكامل
بعثه من جديد او احيائه او اذكاء مره اخرى
مره اخرى بعد ظهور الغزو ايضا في صراعات
غير مباشره في الصراع اللي تكلمنا عن ما
بين القاهره وانقره
ان مصر كانت كل الادوار اللي كانت تركيه
بتحلم تخطط اليها منذ التسعينات قتل او
انه في اه اه اه صراع قادم محتمل ما بين
دول اخرى زي اللي هو الان الاردن توالت ما
بين لبنان واسرائيل انه لبنان بتتهم
اسرائيل بالسطو على مقدرتها من الغاز في
منطقه شرق المتوسط
الاقتراع غير المباشر اللي موجود ما بين
الدول الكبيره وتحديدا الروس والامريكان
الروس حريصه جدا على انه ان لا تترك لما
يجري في شرق المتوسط بعيدا عن اعين ها وان
تحول التحدي الى فرصه لتكون شريكه في هذه
الاكتشافات من خلال الشراكه مع دول
المنطقه المختلفه اذا كانت مصر اذا كانت
اسرائيل اذا كانت لبنان اذا كانت سوريا في
المستقبل
في المقابل الامريكان
بيحاولوا لهم يدفعوا الروس بعيدا عن
المنطقه من خلال مساعده كل الاطراف لانها
تتعاون مع بعض بعيدا عن الروس
السبب الاول ان اللي بيؤدي الى توتر كبير
في منطقه شرق المتوسط وهو اكتشاف الغاز
اللي بيؤدي الى تعاون ما بين بعض الدول
والى توتر واعداء بين دول اخرى اه ال انا
مش مستفيده السبب الثاني اللي تكلمنا عنه
ايضا في حلقات اخرى هو تغيير النظام
العالمي يعني لما كانت الولايات المتحده
تنفرد تماما في صنع القرار وفي غياب او في
بعد انهيار الروس بعد سقوط الاتحاد
السوفياتي
وعدم وجود الصين كقوه مؤثره ومهيمنه ما
كانش فيه مشاكل تذكر يعني في التسعينات
وفي السنوات التي تلتها في البحر المتوسط
بل ان البحر المتوسط نفسه كان مجرى ملاحى
هذه بتعبر من الولايات المتحده وغيرها من
الاساطيل في طريقها الى اماكن التوتر
البحر الاحمر والخليج العربي الامر تغير
بعد
حضراتكم
اكثر من مثال على التغيير الناتج عن تغير
موازين القوى انعكس الزاي على الشرق
الاوسط يعني مثلا لو اخذنا الروس اللي
احنا لسه بنتكلم عليها الروس بعد انهيار
الاتحاد السوفياتي كانوا بلد ضعيفه مستباح
وتخلى عن كثير من الجمهوريات السابقه او
المواليه وعن سيطرته على مجاري مائيه مهمه
جدا
بدا الروس يستعيد مره ثانيه اهتمامهم
الشيء جدا والمبرر والمفهوم في محاوله
امور والسيطره وان يكون عندها
واضح في المجاري المائيه المهمه وخصوصا
المياه الدقيقه واللي يدرس التاريخ الروسي
اعرف ان الروس عندهم الشغب عندهم محاوله
او رغبه مهمه جدا في الوصول الى المياه
فيها لما بنقول كلمه المياه الدقيقه نقصد
بها المجال الملايين في البحر الاحمر
البحر المتوسط الذي تصلح اياها
للملاحه والايام السلام لان الروس صحيح
عندهم كثير من المجال المائيه لكنها تتجمد
في كثير من فصول السنه وبالتالي ما عندهاش
فرصه ان هي تقدر
زودتها وتوسع من نفوذها الا بالوصول الى
المياه الدفاع والروس قالت له العثمانيين
سابقا والاتراك حاليا المائتين سنه في
محاوله منهم للسيطره على البحر الاسود
ومضايق البحر الاسود الدليل والبسفور لانه
هم المنفذ الوحيد
للوصول الى المياه الدفاع في البحر
المتوسط اخيرا تحقق هذا الحلم مش انهم
يصلوا بدليل والاسبوع كندا تم تامين في
سنوات سابقه اصبحت ممرات دوليه لا يستطيع
اتراك ان يمنعوهم او يمنع وغيرهم من
العبور من خلالها ولكن تحقق الحلم لما
الازمه واندلعت الازمه السوريه واقدر
الروس بمبادره جريئه جدا لم تحصل مصالحه
ومصالح لا احنا كعرب وبالتالي استطاعوا ان
اه قاعدتين عسكريتين
يطل على البحر المتوسط المساله شركه
الاهميه نفوس وبدؤوا امنوا المجال الحيوي
حوالي يحاول يقوم علاقات اقوى مع لبنان مع
العراقيين طبعا مع المصريين يحولوا وبداوا
يستعيد وعافيتهم في منطقه البحر المتوسط
قد يكون مثال على التوتر ممكن يجي منين في
الوقت اللي كان القبارصه بيحول ويستعين
بالامريكان ضد ال ال ال التهديدات التركيه
كان الامريكان عرضوا او كان في مناقشه
مهما يضعوا قاعده عسكريه هناك وقبرص مش بس
اه من الحلف الاطلسي كانت النتيجه انه
الروس اللي موجودين على في قواعد عسكريه
قريبه اللي هي موجوده بقي في طرطوس واحمد
حددوا القبائل الا بحضور انهما يسمعوا
باقامه قاعده عسكريه هناك وبالتالي اذا
عدم رغبتهم في انهم يحطوا الروس يعني نفوا
هذه المساله جمله وتفصيلا ما يعني انه في
اطراف كثيره تتصارع على انها تكون موجوده
وتامن وجود هاو ما يكونش فيه اطراف اخرى
دول كبيره يمكن ان تهدد قواعدها ومصالحها
الروس تكلمنا على بلدي الصيني
مش مش حريصه
الضحاك معسكره انها تبعث اساطيل عسكريه
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه هي في مرحله بناء
المصالح الاقتصاديه
وبيزيد رغبتها في تامينها بشكل عسكري زي
ما ذكرنا في حاله البحر الاحمر ببناء مثلا
اول قاعده عسكريه لها خارج الصين في
جيبوتي كمان نفس القصه تنطبق على شرق
البحر المتوسط
الصين اطلقت مشروعها الطموح اللي هو طرق
الحزام والطريقه اللي هدفه الاساسي
افريقيا باسيا باوروبا وتربيه من خلال
الشعب ضخمه جدا من الطرق سواء البحريه او
البريه بحيث تكون يعني شرايين مفتوحه
للتجاره والبضائع والسلع الصينيه لكل دول
العالم من خلال الاستثمارات بتقيمها في كل
هذه المحاور المختلفه واحد من اهم النقاط
الارتكاز في
في نقاط المشروع الحزم والطريق هو شرق
البحر المتوسط في المنطقه اللي تربط
الوضوح اوروبا في الشمال افريقيا في الوسط
وطبعا اه اسيا الى الشرق
ولو تلاحظوا المشروعات الكثيره الى الصين
بتعملها هي ب تتركز حوالين المناطق اللي
يمكن ان تصل بها الى اوروبا عبر البحر
المتوسط او غيره عندها اهتمام كبير بمشروع
محور قناه السويس في مصر لا يمكن يوصلها
اوروبا بسهوله عندها اهتمام كبير بال خط
السكك الحديد اللي عاوزه تعمل اسرائيل ما
بين ايلات و اجدود عشان يحمل البضائع الى
اوروبا عندها اهتمام كبير جدا في مشروع
اليوم السعودي لانه مشروع عنده اطلاله على
البحر الاحمر ومن البحر الاحمر قادر ان
يصل عن طريق مصر الى البحر المتوسط على
شكل الصين مهتمه بما يجري في منطقه شرق
المتوسط باعتبار ان يقع في بؤره اهتمامها
من ناحيه كما انها شديده الحرص على متابعه
التطورات في اي منطقه تكون مصدر الطاقه
سواء كانت رولا وغاز باعتبارها واحده من
اكثر الدول الاستهلاك اللي الطاقه في
العالم ناخذ مثل تلك واخير ممكن نتكلم على
ايران
غير ايران سواء يعني كدوله عندها شعور
عقليه الدوله المحاصره ان هي عندها نفوس
في اماكن الخطر الثلاثه اللي ممكن ياتيها
الخطر من
اللي هو الخليج العربي من البحر الاحمر
حيث توجه لدول الخليج او المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تحديدا وممكن تاتيها الدول
الاخرى الغربيه وطبعا من خلال
وب تحاول ان يكون لها نفوذ كبير ما عندها
النفوس كبير في الخليج العربي وعندها ايضا
بتحاول انها تزود نفوذها في منطقه باب
المندب والبحر الاحمر وتحاول تمد نفوذها
بشكل دؤوب مستمر رغم الضغوط الامريكيه
والاسرائيليه وصولا الى البحر المتوسط
لاسباب كثيره ازمه تجاريه بحته انها تؤمن
طريق مباشره لوصول بضائعها الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي او دول اوروبا برا الاول عن طريق
العراق ممر ارض العراق سوريا ثم البحر
المتوسط وكذلك استخدام البحر المتوسط
كوسيله للضغط عسكريا على الاسرائيليين مع
الامريكان اننا قادره على زي ما انا
استطيع انا اثير المتاعب الى خصوما واعداء
كما فعلت في الخليج العربي وكما فعلت في
البحر الاحمر في ايضا بتستخدم البحر
المتوسط وحلفاؤه هناك وتحديدا حزب الله
علشان تكون
نقط الدفاع
اماميه للدفاع عن مصالحها ضد خصومه ضد
اعدائها في المنطقه هناك اشكركم والى لقاء
اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]